welcome to this video playing cow from
from the US and let's see tirage
recently a friend told me that a success
some interesting points let's see the
point is that move this g5 idea is not
not uncommon at all nowadays it's played
in all kinds of French positions and
also in various terrorist positions
there is a line where this Bishop is on
e 7 and the pawn on 87 so obvious
difference difference is that we should
be five check it's not possible anymore
and I might be able to take on c5 and
one youth so one there are ways to just
win the pawn hmm interesting of course
it's a very loose position so it's not
just check on and living happily ever
after now there is very very nicely
developed so Bishop d7 and prepare non
castle would actually blunder the d5
pawn yeah so this I probably should
avoid
but how should I develop Queen to e7 I
need to move the Queen to to get castle
long now White has definite compensation
hmm
not sure though how exactly should
proceed one way is to play a Fosse form
maybe it's something like c4 and even
before to get there should be two in yep
okay if I take it I take it and then I
cannot go Bishop g7 because b7 hangs
well I don't want to play default
default so looks doesn't look right
giving up before I enter and the like
I'm not sure how to how to untangle okay
let's take it maybe I should have gone
back Quincy seven gives away g5 yeah I
am it looks very dangerous for me you
can we can even just play b3 Bishop b2 I
have Bishop deform before I give bishop
deform this is some at least something
okay i still cannot go Bishop d7 a rupee
aid also looks strange it's not exactly
a prep for castling long
I can go to before probably i'll never
cast long anyway so let's try that b5
and yeah I haven't I have this move
controlling the long diagonal then he's
got that one hmm yeah this is of course
changed now with the rukon beard wow
this looks like like complete and those
sharp lines they can really hit you back
in the face look g1 just ripped your
money the throg deform I'm not even sure
what I playing against that move
yeah this is just hanging him ah what
the heck
well what did your take play my meme
yeah you don't develop anything are you
you deserve you you re deserve to lose
like that
check hmm Jeff if this was the best one
I really don't maybe it's it's enough to
win but I'm sure he had something better
even okay this isn't even a winner hmm
ok is winning on time anyway because of
this because of the non increments time
control therefore it didn't even need to
to look for a good moves but high-margin
this position not even sure if I prefer
white ok maybe you will get both answer
yeah
check ya know I'm just better never get
the Paul I think
maybe yes some tactics as possible check
check check check check check check yeah
I know you same time I could also just
just resign check check check grah on
her check I thought I did was I effects
I have it was a repetition yeah but ok
cannot play the opening in that way what
the heck did i do him I mean it probably
didn't even look for some good moves
because it was clear that I lost some
time that I'll lose on time 56 is quite
quite obviously not the best move you
just don't trade down on your active
pieces for a bad end game or at least
not not the best possible even before if
he had some better horses is pretty
clear queen bee three years plus 11 just
for instance I mean you really need to
made here and so I cannot be content
with getting the palm back but what did
I am I mean this is really a viable line
it's not it's risky and everything but
it shouldn't be bad for like here ok but
to take care taking here cannot be that
bad go on route would be one around here
I probably need to need to improve yeah
this is Sam maybe not the best term
I have this problem after see for that I
don't really want to i need to take and
then I cannot develop now our Queenie
semanas probably not a good setup maybe
I need to protect this pawn and then try
for Queen c7 Bishop d7 maybe even
sacrificing the porn along the way this
could be an idea let's say just for
example is not necessarily a Best Play
am Bishop here and if he takes just a
move like this and then long castles
this could be let's say here here and
then I can go here or maybe here and i
have i have a decent development yeah
this is much better than what I did
around here we are it's really really
dangerous and this is probably really
bad it looks how it looks it is very
risky anyway maybe I need to go Bishop
deform but you don't really want to move
it again yeah maybe still Luke p8 was
really bad because it is such a loose
piece and this is maybe an approach for
Queen f6 if I would exchange Queens I'm
immediately okay but very tricky
can I have this idea this may be really
okay Bishop deform White has very good
compensation but it doesn't seem to be a
very critical for black and after that
I'm probably losing yeah this is this is
dead loss he have no i havena muthiya
absolutely no play ones check yeah and
with this he just keeps me the edge
again but probably oh wait check ah this
is this is very cute I didn't consider
that I can just play here completely
forgot about that this is much better
even I have instant coordination here
okay yeah this so the computer gives us
better for whites but I'm not I'm not
entirely convinced yeah maybe it is
better for what he can get this pawn but
only just moves later black was better
again but okay it didn't matter because
I lost some time anyway and the
interesting point is how to untangle in
this in this opening I think this Bishop
deform idea was better alright thanks
for watching